Nó này 20 sảo tháng 6 là 2 người khu trăm 5 năm, theo thông tin từ bình định như đồng hay,
tình phố chính mình, đơn vị vừa cấp lưu thình câu bây gái mở,
tám tuổi ở bình thật, bị đa trình thương, hôm nay sâu, rất là tên ạc cửa quốn.
Theo ra đình, tối ngày 20 2 tháng 6, 1 người khu trăm 5 năm,
1 người đăng trơi cùng chỉ gái.
Sâu đó, người mẹ nhiều chị đi lấy sữa và chỉ mở cửa quốn đi dàng ngoài,
khiến đấy mở bị đu thè cửa quốn lên.
Ê phút sông, chỉ gái phát hiện mở bị quốn và cửa.
Mẹ nập tức được chuyển đến bình định đa khó an tốt,
phát hiện trong tình trạm tìm tái, hôm nay không còn phản đối.
Giờ trên thương nà, mẹ được chuyển gấp trong đến bình định bị đồng hay.
Tại đây, mẹ được chình đoàn có nhiều trên thương,
và có vi cơ tổn thương náo giò thiếu o cí,
các bác sĩ đã tư để á dụ phương phát hiện như sự đoàn bảo vệ ná bộ trong gia đình như kiện.
Sâu bốn ngày đuí sĩ tích cửa, hiện bẹ được gái máy thở, tình tháo,
nhìn đi tựng mười thân.
Theo các chuyển gà, tên hạnh cửa của thị phòng chánh được,
nếu ra đến cình trọng hơn trong việc lựa trọng và sự dụng lại cửa này.
Hí sự dụng cửa của nha, các gia đình điệu tiên lại có cảm biến tự dụng hoặc đạo chíu phía gặp tất cả.
Mù điều khiến đến đặt ở nơi trẻ không với tối, nếu lắp tế nút tắt hình gấp,
trẻ em cần được gió không đủ, lao hoặc xem cửa của nha cho chơi.
Không nên cho chơi cần cửa của nha là phía tích bị đăng hoạt động.
Trong cho hợp xe ra tên, việc xe biểu đúng các vật đưa trẻ đến cơ sở y tế kì thời là vô cùng quan trọng,
giúp tăng cơ hội sống và vụ của ý chú chè.